[موسيقى]
تروي طرفه من الادب الشعبي ان رجلا سال
الامام الاشبيلي عن الكموج ما هو الكموج
فساله الاشبيلي واين قراتها اجاب الرجل في
قول امرئ القيس وليل كموج البحر ارخص دوله
فقال الاشبيلي بنبره من يتقبل التعازي
بفقدان حبيب
الكموز يا عزيزي هو دابه تقرا ولا تفهم
الى العناوين
تحت العدوان وفوق العجز العربيه عن نجم
الاحتلال
السويد تبيح مجددا الاساءه للقران الكريم
ودعوات لمقاطعتها
السويد تهجر كنائسها والفاتيكان يتضامن مع
المسلمين
فرنسا تغلي وتحترق ومكرون يرقص في حقل
صاخب
الفتى الضحيه نائل فرنسي بكامل الحقوق
وليس جاليه جزائريه
منع محجبه من دخول مسبح في لبنان في غياب
تحركات حقوقيه
من يطرح الحج الافتراضي عبر تطبيق الزوم
والميتافيرس
[موسيقى]
مرحبا هل من الحكمه تاسيس كتائب مقاومه
فلسطينيه توجع الاسرائيليه لكنها لا تجليه
عن الارض بل تستجلب ردا من الاحتلال على
طريقه بعض الانظمه العربيه
بحديد ونار لا يميزان بين مقاتل ومدني طفل
وكبير امراه ورجل رد تدميري شامل لا طاقه
لبشر به فهل تتشكل المقاومات في البلاد
لتلقي بشعوبها الى التهلكه اسئله ان
طرحتها على نفسك فانت لست خائلا للوطن
والامه بل ان ولاءك للوطن والامه هو
الدافع وراء ورشه تساؤلاتك الوطنيه لقد
سيقت هذه الاسئله الى حكيم فاجاب اولا من
قواميس اللغات فسال عن ابرز اسماء الارض
قيل له الام
فاستحلف السائل ان يجيب هل تنام في بيتك
وتاكل العنب البارد اذا خطفت جماعه من
اللصوص امك ونكلت بها لا وربي ومن التاريخ
المجيد استشهد الحكيم فسال هل كان انبياء
الله عليهم السلام يرمون بايدي اتباعهم
الى التهلكه عندما قاموا الظلم على كل
صعيد ولنا في عيسى بن مريم عليهما السلام
مثال ساطع يغنينا عن الاستشهاد بثورات
الشعوب الحديثه حول العالم التي لم تبخل
بدماء ابنائها فقدمتها سخيه على طريق
الاستقلال فلا تدعوا وساوس الشيطان تحرف
البوصله يختم الحكيم ولا تظنوا ان مقاومي
جنين وكل فلسطين لم يدب قلوبهم مشهد التغ
ريبه الفلسطينيه الاحدث عندما اجبر
المحتلون مئات العائلات في مخيم جنين على
مغادره منازلها تحت زخات القصف والقنص
والاجتياح لكنهم يقاومون
وسيستمرون يقول حتى لا يقال ان اهل جنين
باعوا ارضك يا فلسطين
[موسيقى]
تحمي القدس يا ربي يا رب يا ربي تحمي
الكود سياره
يا رب العالمين
تحمي مخيم جيني يا رب العالمين
تحميم وخيم جنين
عندما كان الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق بيل
كلينتون سيد البيت الابيض اقتربت منه
متدربه في القصر الرئاسي تدعى مونيكا
لوينسكي اغرته حتى اغوته فاقام معها علاقه
محرمه وعابره تقول التقارير فاصبحت مونيكا
بارادتها او رغما عنها اشهر فتاه او غير
ذلك على امتداد العالم في تلك الفتره
لكنها شهره جعلتها تفكر لاحقا بالانتحار
المراه التي اغوت الرئيس
وادخلته في علاقه جنسيه
مونيكا صامويل لونسكي لحقت الفضيحه مونيكا
على مدى عقدين من الزمن وتصدرت عناوين
معظم الصحف والمجلات لفترات طويله شعرت
بالعار والندم والعزله فكرت كثيرا
بالانتحار ما ذكرنا بمونيكا مونيكا
عاشت لياليها في البيت الابيض
وموميكا سلوان سود وجه السويد الاسود مع
المسلمين هكذا علقوا
مميته هذا عراقي مسيحي سابق كان قائدا
للمليشيا المسماه عيسى بن مريم او كتائب
صقور السريان في اطار الحشد الشعبي
العراقي وبسبب صراعه مع زعيم ميليشيا
بابليون المسيحيه المتطرفه ايضا ريان
الكلداني المصنف دوليا على انه ارهابي
غادر موميكا العراق الى السويد طالبا
اللجوء فيها
متبرئا من بلاد الرافدين ومن شعبها وقد
سبق ان اعتقلته السلطات العراقيه بتهمه
ارتكاب جرائم حرب ليعرف عن نفسه بعدها
بانه ملحد ومفكر وكاتب
على اعتذار من الكتاب والمفكرين هذا
الارهابي اللطيف على ارصفه السويد اقدم
على الاساءه لنسخه مكرمه من المصحف الشريف
نمتنع وندعو الى الامتناع عن نشر صور
الجريمه
ليس قضيتنا في الحلقه بل ان قوانين السويد
في التعدي على المقدسات الاسلاميه وغيرها
احيانا هي القضيه لان للولد مميكا كما وصف
مارب شخصيه تتعلق بتعزيز ظروف لجوئه
وبتسوله الاموال عن طريق الاحتيال على
اليمينيين المتطرفين بعد طلبه الدعم
النقديه لتمويل جرائمه التي لا تحتاج
لاكثر من قداحه او عود ثقاب
اللي حابب يشارك مظاهره ويدعم معنويا
ماديا رابط البايبل تحت اسمي بحسابي
المسلمون المسالمون في السويد كان ردهم
الاحتجاجي دعاء وصلاه جمعه في ساحات
البرلمان السويدي في ستوكهولم اللهم فرج
الكرب عن
بيانات التنديد والاستنكار لجريمه حرق
المصحف طافت العالم من واشنطن الى موسكو
لكن الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين اقتنص الفرصه
فقصد احد المساجد الاثريه في روسيا ليؤكد
ان القران مقدس في بلاده عموما وليس لدى
المسلمين فقط
فاستبشر معارضون سوريون خيرا بالتصريح لعل
بوتين يامر بفتح تحقيقات عسكريه حول ما
قالوا انه تدمير التحالف الذي تقوده موسكو
لمساجد وانتهاك حرمه مقدسات اسلاميه في
سوريا خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
انه مقدس للمسلمين وللاخرين نحن نعلم ان
بلدان اخرى تتصرف بشكل مختلف فهم لا
يحترمون المشاعر الدينيه للناس روسيا تكون
احتراما شديدا للقران ولمشاعر المسلمين
الدينيه وعدم احترام هذا الكتاب المقدس في
روسيا جريمه معظم الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه استلت ريشتها من محبرتها وكتبت
بيانات استنكار جديده نقلا عن معلقات
قديمه من ارشيفها المشرف كما تم استدعاء
السفير السويدي في اكثر من عاصمه لشرب
القهوه العربيه
واستنكار حرق المصحف الشريف لكن العين على
تركيا التي يمكنها ان تؤدب السويد كما
قالوا اكثر من غيرها بمنعها من الانضمام
الى حلف الناتو الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
تحدث عن درس سوف تلقبه تركيا لما وصفه
بالغطرسه الغربيه
عاجلا ام اجلا سنعلم رموز الغطرسه الغربيه
ان اهانه مقدسات المسلمين ليست حريه فكر
وتركيا لن ترضخ ابدا لسياسات الاستفزاز او
التهديد ومن يرتكبون جريمه حرق القران في
السويد ومن يسمحون بها تحت غطاء حريه
الفكر لن يبلغ اهدافهم وسنبدي رده فعل
باقوى طريقه ممكنه حتى يتم محاربه
التنظيمات الارهابيه واعداء الاسلام بحسم
لكن الامين العام لحلف الناتو يؤكد ان
المفاوضات ستستمر مع تركيا حول عضويه
ستوكهولم في الحلف واعتبر ان احراق المصحف
مدان لكنه ليس مخالفا للقانون في السويد
معزوفه القانون وحريه التعبير نفسها
كررتها وزاره الخارجيه السويديه في بيان
متاخر استنكر الاساءه للقران الكريم لكنه
ذكر في الوقت ذاته بان حريه كبير او بين
مزدوجين حريه اهانه المقدسات الاسلاميه حق
يكفله الدستور في السويد فكيف كان موقف
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي بيان وزاره
الخارجيه السويديه اتى بعدما عقدت منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي التي تضم 57 دوله
اجتماعا دعت فيه الى اتخاذ تدابير جماعيه
لمنع هذه الحوادث ذكر الكتاب الحكومه
السويديه بان حريه التعبير والسويتين
بتوعها لم تسمح لها بمنح رخصه لرجل تقدم
في يناير الماضي بطلب تلخيص مستنكر بطبيعه
الحال لحرق كتاب اليهود المقدس امام
السفاره الاسرائيليه في ستوكهولم كما
يمنعون اي اساءه للمثليين بينما لا تنطبق
ذات المعايير على جموع المسلمين الذين
يرون بالسويد تحديدا بلدا يصر على
استفزازهم خاصه ان ليست المره الاولى التي
تجري فيها مثل هذه الحادثه امام العجز
الرسمي عن حمايه المقدسات يلجا المسلمون
الى مظاهرات حصلت في اكثر من دوله كما وجه
الازهر الشريف والبرلمان العربي دعوات
لمقاطعه المنتجات السويديه
طلب الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه بمقاطعه
المنتجات السويديه وعدم السفر الى السويد
ردا على موافقه السلطات بهذا البلد بحرق
نسخ من المصحف الشريف يؤكد موقع السويد
الرسمي ان سبعين بالمئه من السويديين لا
يعبرون عن ثقتهم بالكنيسه
بالتالي فان تشريعات السويد ليست صناعه
مسيحيه بل لا دينيه ولا ادريه والحاديه
باب الفاتيكان فرنسيس ادان تلخيص الحكومه
السويديه بحرق المصحف الشريف وعليه لا
تكون جريمه الاساءه الراهنه صراعا بين
مسلمين ومسيحيين بل بين المسلمين
والاستبداد الالحادي واللاديني
كلامنا هذا لا يبرر شيئا ولا يقلل بتاتا
من فظاعه جريمه الاساءه للقران الكريم لكن
ليس من العدل ان تحمل الكنيسه الحديثه
مسؤوليه افعال تضررت بنفسها وما تزال قبل
المسلمين
ويسخر اللاتينيون دائما من دين المسيحيين
ومقدساتهم في عقر دارهم حزينه
وعيشوا بالسويد بتعرفوا السويد بالنسبه
لالنا نحن هو باوروبا اكثر بلد متقدم
ومتطور وسالت لها المراه شو الحياه اللي
عايشينها بره
قالت لي ابونا ما في حياه وخبرتني كيف شو
نوع المجتمع قد ما في حريات وقد ما في هيك
ممنوع تجبر شيء لحدا ممنوع تعلم ولادك على
الصلاه قالت لي ما فينا نقول لهم شيء
لاولادنا وبيو
عليها ما فيك تحكي ما فيك تقول له ما فيك
تعلموا عن الله بيتمسخروا عليه بالمدرسه
اذا قال انه بحب يسوع لانه ما في الله بقى
بالكتب تقول التقارير ان الملايين من
المسيحيين قد تركوا دينهم في السويد التي
بيعت نحو 100 كنيسه فيها السويديون يتركون
دينهم او يذهبون لاتباع طوائف اخرى وقد
ادى ذلك الى بيع حوالي 100 كنيسه وذلك
بسبب عدم وجود اتباع واعطاء للحضور وفقا
لصحيفه سي 24 السويديه سيكون هناك المزيد
من المنفصلين عن الكنيسه السويديه خلال
السنوات القادمه بعض الكنائس المباعه في
السويد تحولت الى مساجد عندما عرضت للبيع
امر يحزن رجال الدين المسيحيين لكنهم في
النهايه سيفضلون تحولها الى مساجد على ان
تصبح حالات ليليه كما حصل في اوروبا
الكنائس المهجوره في اوروبا اختلف مصيرها
ففي هولندا مثلا تحولت احدى الكنائس لسوبر
ماركت واخرى لمتجر زهور وثالثه لمشاري كتب
ورابعه لنادي رياضي وهناك كنيسه تحولت الى
حانه يقولوا صاحبها انه لم يستمع الى اي
شكوى بخصوص ذلك وزير الخارجيه الايطالي
انطونيو تجاني مسيحي متدين يقول ان الرابط
المشتركه في اوروبا هو الدين المسيحي وهذا
صحيح والمسلمون ايضا يقولون ان الاسلام
يجمعنا ليش بدنا نستحي او نكذب على بعض
لكن هل تستطيع ايطاليا وفرنسا واليونان
واسبانيا وغيرها ان توقف المد اللاديني
والالح الذي يجتاح امتهم في اوروبا عن
بكره ابيها المسلمون قاوموا ويقاومون فهل
يقاوم المسيحيون يسال المهتمون وقال جتني
في تغريده له هناك قاسم مشترك يربط كل
اوروبا وهو المسيحيه من روما الى برلين
ومن باريس الى لشبونه ومن مدريد الى اثينا
وحتى دول البلطيق سنجد دائما صليبا نحن
ندافع عن قيمنا وهويتنا وجذورنا
عندما سئل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
من بيروت عن ثوره تشرين الشبابيه الشعبيه
على المنظومه الحاكمه احتكم الى الشعب
شعبي لبنان علما ان اعمال شغب مدانه
ومرفوضه رافقت ثوره تشرين لقد تحدثت عن
الحراك وعن الشعب اللبناني منذ 17 من
اكتوبر هل هذه دعوه لثوره جديده ان الثوره
لا تحدث عبر الدعوات وانما الشعب والقوه
السياسيه هم من يقررون القيام بها
الزجاج عم بيتم بطريقه عشوائيه عم بتم
اشعال النار ايضا على الطريق وتكسير زجاج
المباني الصوره اللي عم بتوديها عن نفسها
اعمال الشغب والتخريب واحراق السيارات
وسرقه المتاجر انتقلت من لبنان الى فرنسا
ولا سيما في منطقه نانتير احدى ضواحي
باريس على خلفيه قتل الشرطه للمراهق نائل
مرزوقي البالغ من العمر 17 عاما على حاجز
للتفتيش المروري
فيضواحي باريس بحجه عدم امتثاله لامر
التوقف بدايه لا شيء يبرر احراق السيارات
ونهب الممتلكات الخاصه والعامه خلو احمد
موسى يعلم عليهم يسجل عليهم النقاط قدامك
اهو لقطه عجيبه جدا رادار طب الرادار هي
عملوا الاسره دي
اللي تعبوا نفسهم ونزلوا فكوا الرادار
ياخدوه ويحملوه في عربيه هيعملوا ايه
والله العظيم مهزله رغم بشاعه مشهد
التخريب المتكرر بفرنسا حتى بعد المباريات
الرياضيه احيانا لكن من هو الاب الحقيقي
لمشاعر الاحتقان لدى ابناء الضواحي انه
التهميش الذي صنع احزمه فقر موقوته قابله
للانفجار احداث ينظر اليها على نطاق واسع
على انها نتيجه لعقود من التهميش والتمييز
طال شباب الضواحي تشكلت هذه الضواحي في
خمسينيات القرن الماضي بعدما جلبت فرنسا
عماله اجنبيه من مستعمراتها واسكنتهم في
تجمعات محدده حتى صارت تشكل احزمه للفقر
ركز الاعلام الفرنسي على جزئيه ان الفتى
نائل والذين ثاروا بعد مقتله هم مهاجرون
من اصول جزائريه وافريقيه
لكن الاصح هو انهم فرنسيون يحبون فرنسا
والعيش فيها ولد معظمهم فيها ولا يتقنون
غالبا غير لغتها والده نائل لا تعتبر
ابنها من الرعايه الجزائريين في فرنسا بل
تطالب حكومه باريس بانصافه كمواطن فرنسي
قتلته الشرطه بدم بارد
عندما تشاهد الشرطه الفرنسيه تعتدي على
شاب مصاب بمتلازمه داون فانك لن تستغرب
ابدا قتل مراهق على حاجز مروري
تتعرض الشرطه الفرنسيه منذ سنوات
الانتقادات انها تستخدم تكتيكات اعنف
واكثر قسوه من اي مكان اخر في اوروبا حساب
الرابع التركي في تويتر ذكر بالرسم
الكاريكاتوري لمجله تشارلي عندما سخرت من
ضحايا زلزال تركيا وقالت لا داعي لارسال
الدبابات فكتب الرابع التركي على صوره
لحرائق شوارع فرنسا واليوم نقول لهم لا
داعي لارسال مسيرات بيرقدار هذا الكلام لن
ينال من هدوء بال الرئيس ماكرون الذي لم
تعكر الاحتجاجات والاضطرابات في شوارع
بلاده صفوه مشاركته في حفله صاخبه بحسب
التقرير
في باريس وبينما الفوضى والاحتجاجات
واعمال الشغب
والشوارع الفرنسيه
كان الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
زوجته بنجاد في حفل للمغني البريطاني كما
جاء في الفيديو الذي تداوله ناشطون على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والذي صور من دون
معرفه ماكرون اضافه الى التقاطه صورا
تذكاريه مع جون
تذكرون الاعتصام والمسيره النسويه الى
شاطئ مدينه صيدا اللبنانيه مؤخرا بسبب
قرار البلديه الزام الرواد الشاطئ باللباس
المحتسم وكيف تحول من عمر امراه من النزول
بالمايوه الى قضيه راي عام وكيف ان الرئيس
حزب الكتائب النائب سامي الجميل وجه سؤالا
خطيا الى الحكومه حول الحادثه مستندا بذلك
الى مواد الدستور الضامنه للحريات الشخصيه
هذه الحريات لم تشمل هذا الاسبوع حريه
حجاب امراه طردت على مدخل مسبح محظور على
المحجبات بما يخالف قانون منع التمييز
علما انها حادثه تتكرر مثيلاتها منذ عده
سنوات
المدربه الاجتماعيه زينه زين تروي ما حدث
معها من امتهان لحقوقها المدنيه وتمييز
اول ما وصلنا انا اصلا ما بالبوسبورتين
وما بسبح فقط محجبه عن الباب واكيدي ما
خصه الشاب واللي موجودين على الباب ما
دخلوهم اول ما بيشوفوني بيقولوا لي ممنوع
دخول المحجبات مش قصه السباحه المحجبه
شخصيا مثل ما هي ممنوعه تفوت الاعلاميه
البصريه لميس الحديدي تحمل الجيل المسلم
الجديد سؤالا لم يطرحه ابدا فتقول لماذا
لا يكون الحج افتراضيا عبر الانترنت
يسالون الحج اون لاين
وكيف يرجمون ابليس يا لميس الحج ليه ما
نعملش الحج بالميتافيرس ليه ما نعملش الحج
اون لاين يعني نعمله
بالزوم بقى كده والحاجات دي الحاجات تطورت
ليه لازم نروح نلف حوالين الكعبه سبع مرات
وهذا ليس رايي انا بسال اسئله
ختاما عام
1890 الف الكاتب الفرنسي ماركي دو بوني
دراما بعنوان محمد لتحويلها الى مسرحيه
تسيء لمقام النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام
اعلنت الصحف عن الشروع في تحضيرها لعرضها
في المسارح وبلغ الخبر ديوان السلطان
العثماني عبد الحميد الثاني الذي ارسل على
الفور خطابا حازما الى الرئيس الفرنسي
صديقي يطلب فيه التراجع عن فكره المسرحيه
التي تتجاوز الفن الى الصراع بين الدول
واستدعى السلطان السفيره الفرنسيه في
اسطنبول قمت مون بيلا حمله الى باريس
تهديدا مباشرا بقطع العلاقات العثمانيه
الفرنسيه اذا تم السماح بعرض المسرحيه في
فرنسا التي منعتها فورا استجابه لطلب او
تهديد السلطان
لكن الكاتب لم يئس فنزح الى لندن محاولا
اكثر من مره الحصول على تلخيص من السلطات
البريطانيه بعرض المسرحيه فتمكن السلطان
ايضا من منعها بل وادها في كل اوروبا
رحم الله السلطان عبد الحميد الى اللقاء
سمعنا انكم قد رتبتم من اجل تمثيل مسرحيه
وهي تحوي اهانه لرسولنا
انا
سلطان البلقان
والعراق
وسوريا وجبل لبنان
سلطان الحجاز والقفقاس
وسلطان الاناضول وسلطان العاصمه انا
خليفه الاسلام عبد الحميد خان
ان لم توقفوا تلك المسرحيه ساهدم الدنيا
على رؤوسكم
[موسيقى]